ins bewusstsein die eine frage wie es
weitergehen soll
mit mitte 50 und später wenn das alter
bleischwer die lebensgeister müde macht
wie will man wohnen
allein zu zweit im heim in einer
gemeinschaft fragen die in diesem buch
aufgeworfen werden
es erzählt von einem mutigen wohnprojekt
dem stürmer aus in bern
in diesem ehemaligen spital haben die
autorinnen margareta hehl und barbara
zur in gemeinsam mit acht anderen frauen
und männern eine wohngemeinschaft
gegründet an einsamkeit keine
zweisamkeit sondern wohnen als einen
gemeinsamen neubeginn und bewusst sie
wenn möglich ist
in ihrem buch schildern sie die nicht
immer einfachen sensiblen prozess sich
von der vergangenheit von gewohnheiten
zu lösen
sie beschreiben wie sich die gruppe erst
mal finden musste
wie man sich gegenseitig kennen lernte
bedürfnisse formuliert die vorstellung
von gemeinschaft
die abgrenzung zum privaten
um all dies zu erproben verreisten sie
gemeinsam ins piemont
um die theorie konkret werden zu lassen
himmel probetag diskussionen kam mir
sogar schemata mutter gemacht wie viel
honig und mit dem protokoll gemacht und
hält seine gäste mit seiner tochter das
ist der ort wo musik spüren weil ich sie
so bei bruchsal luxus csi philosophie
vom leib und starb mit lied klingt das
und der schlechte heime natürlich
intensiver füße gelegentlich das modell
sterne haus bietet eine mischung aus
nähe und distanz gemeinschaftsräumen
denen auch kulturelle veranstaltungen
angeboten werden und wohneinheiten in
denen paare und einzelpersonen ihre
privatsphäre finden die genossenschaft
verwaltet das haus demokratisch wird
über gemeinsame aktivitäten entschieden
das leben in arbeitsgruppen hätten
denn das zusammenleben verändert sich
ständig wird neu definiert und
aufeinander abgestimmt es gibt
verschiedene philosophien verschiedenen
immer einig und die müsse immer im
gleichen topf sie und es gibt die ganze
vielfalt von einem user sie wem das
immer noch spannend als sie 1996
begannen das projekt zu planen waren sie
alle etwas über 50 sie gaben sich das
wort füreinander zu sorgen wenn später
gebrechlichkeit
oder krankheit den alltag die letzten
drücker
es funktioniert wie sie eigentlich noch
zehn bis zwölf personen wo ist die
diagnose parkinson hat aber sich das
besitzlos peter fritz machen berger ist
nun der erste der ernsthaft erkrankt ist
parkinson so lange wie möglich wird der
teil der störer aus gemeinschaft bleiben
alter als therapie becker kein sieg mehr
in pakistan leben normal aber und das
halte dein gang auch wie jugendliche
aber jetzt zugespitzt und langsam seine
grenzen
sam
die grenzen sie werden spürbar
für die generation 50plus was tun mit
dem rest des lebens noch einmal den
aufbruch wagen und sohn bekannte alt